en direct dans cette édition marc
lavergne directeur de recherche au cnrs
spécialiste de la corne de l'afrique
bonjour un marc lavergne merci de
répondre à nos questions je lis abeba
clame sa victoire le tigre et dit
poursuivre la résistance qui croire ça
dépend de quelle victoire on parle à la
victoire sur le terrain
y a pas de doute que grâce à la maîtrise
de plaire c'est l'armée fédérale qui l'a
emporté et le f qualité s'est retiré en
bon ordre de la capitale pour épargner
la population
donc ça c'est quelque chose quand même
d'assez positif le fait qu' il n'y ait
pas de visiblement à cette heure de
vengeance de l'armée fédérale sur la
population qui a été épargné en revanche
le tplf les aspérités serti plié en bon
ordre dit il pour lancer une guérilla
dans les montagnes mesalles semblerait
qu'ils contrôlent encore des villes de
province lors la question est de savoir
au delà eu des demandes qui sont lancés
par l'onu et puis de cette médiation par
l'union africaine qui sont assez décalé
par rapport à la marche des événements
et bien sur le terrain comment les
choses vont évoluer c'est à dire est-ce
que de petit problème de connexion je me
permets de vous couper
vous venez de parler de l'onu qui
appelle au calme
quelle marge de manoeuvre justement de
la part des nations unies puis quelle
marge de manoeuvre également de l'union
africaine a aussi je crois que
l'ethiopie en tant que siège de l'union
africaine est un peu redevable quand
même de deux réponses à cette volonté de
médiation africaine en revanche l'onu
l'onu est apparu un peu lointaine et est
un peu inopérantes dans cette affaire
depuis le début dans la mesure où il
s'agit d'une question intérieure d'un
pays membre et que les textes de l'onu
ne lui permet pas d'intervenir
l'onu dénonce également un profilage
ethnique la scission communautaire est
ce que c'est la seule origine de ce
conflit ou bien s'il ya d'autres causes
et si vous nickel évidemment non non
justement où
bien que l'erythrée par exemple a pris
fait et cause pour le gouvernement
central alors que l'erythrée est dirigée
on peut dire est majoritairement peuplé
par des tigres est un donc il ya une
sorte de style it est un terreau tigré
aide qui s'explique essentiellement par
l'histoire par une histoire coloniale
par l'histoire aussi de la lutte pour
l'indépendance de l'erythrée
donc je pense qu'il s'agit pas du tout
d'une question ethnique il n'y a pas de
revanche à prendre
dedans en cette partie là du tigre est
en tout cas ça n'est pas vrai près de la
frontière soudanaise où les amharas ont
une revanche à prendre sur les tigres
est un qui se sont installés sur leurs
terres quarante cinq mille réfugiés au
soudan des missiles envoyés sur asmara
quid d'une heure régionalisation du
conflit à l'ensemble de la corne de
l'afrique
donc je pense que personne n'est prêt
pour l'instant les soudanais ne prennent
pas fait et cause ni pour les uns ni
pour les autres dirais que ja il ya une
sorte de petite difficulté en ce moment
à propos du grand barrage de la
renaissance entre l'ethiopie le soudan
et l'egypte bon c'est quelque chose qui
ne font pas je dirais mêlée avec 7,7 au
fond des sikhs nom de l'ethiopie sur des
bases juridiques nouvelle que prône le
gouvernement fédéral et monsieur a bien
mais alors derrière lui il ya quand même
une revendication de tous les peuples de
l'ethiopie à l'encontre des tigres et à
qui avaient accaparé le pouvoir pendant
près de 30 ans mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut confondre le peuple tigréens
et le front populaire de libération du
tigre et qui est actuellement en base de
retraite en en face de retraité et qui
n'a pas forcément l'assentiment de toute
sa population
qu'est-ce qu'il faut presque il faut
s'attendre lors des prochains jours
après on le rappelle un trois semaines
de combats ben je pense que sur le
terrain les choses pourrait s'enliser
tant que le front populaire de
libération du tigre et à des moyens de
résister salaires des moyens en
logistique on le ravitaillement dans les
montagnes ça n'est pas évident et puis
il n'ya pas cette expérience qui avait
lors leurs parents il ya 30 ou 40 ans
quand il se battait effectivement
contre l'armée du dictateur rouge mais
glisse tout haïlé mariam aller les
choses l'histoire ne peut pas se
réécrire donc je pense que sans soutien
extérieur sans soutien à l'intérieur
d'un point de vue concret c'est-à-dire
au ravitaillement le fpt va engager des
négociations si le chrono son crâne s'y
prête
merci marc lavergne d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche au cnrs
spécialiste de la corne de l'afrique